hi i'm david henry and i'm here with
buzzfeed
to read your thirst tweets
[Music]
i'm nervous all right number one david
henry kiss me well
i'm married don't think she'd like that
but uh very nice of you i appreciate it
i want to be harper finkel's friend so
we can both
thirst about how hot justin russo is
while wearing fruit hats
that is so weird why the fruit hat
justin russo was on my top three quote
hot white boys end quote list
in high school his glow up was so
sexy to me here's the thing about that i
don't know
what a glow up is the problem in life is
that i'm in love with david henry from
which is place and he doesn't know i
exist
well guess what now i know you exist
david henry
is not a snack not a meal but a whole
buffet
i like buffets so we have that in common
oh wow david henry has a really nice
butt
you can thank my italian heritage for
that i didn't
have much to do with it it's something i
was born with but um
thank you i hope i'm not the only one
still up late at night dreaming about
david henry casting wizard spells
with his massive waverly wand to win my
that's the weirdest thing i've ever read
david henry can i pay you on cameo to
punch me in the face
that's a little aggressive i will not do
that nope david henry can punch me in
the face then break my
arms and i'd thank him probably
why are we just gonna ignore the fact
that david henry aka justin russo is a
complete daddy now that's right
i am a daddy i very much have a little
daughter she's really cute
you might be using daddy in a different
way that
again i'm like not privy to i have a
feeling there might be a little bit of
that there and i'm not sure what to do
with that
david henry can be my full-time daddy
okay yeah i've confirmed that daddy is
not being used
in the way that i think it should be
used and
it's weird thank you buzzfeed for having
me read some thirsty tweets
that was a lot of fun and make sure you
all check out my film this is the year
on august 28th for a live virtual
premiere event
with me and executive producer selena
gomez we're reuniting for
[Music]